citizens of the reject Nation we are
back joined by the Terra Erickson hello
hello what are we watching today Tara
be Fantastic Four the second one Rise
of the Silver Surfer neither of us have seen this
movie if you didn't catch our reaction before the
upstairs first time watching in my first time
re-watching after like I don't know 15 20 or
something like that people say this one is better
I'm looking forward to this right here right now
first order business go ahead leave a like we know
how that feels Tara what do they do ring that Bell
ring ring ring ring ring ring ring the subscribers
are coming did you just turn into the Hunchback of
another day that's what I did and lastly full
length three action watch long recent their
own copy of Fantastic Four resin Silver Surfer
we're watching this on the D Plus available for
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page massive
thank you to all who have joined us it's been
coming so much stuff lately oh we're still
cover many things exclusively over there with
reaction highlights and Watch Dogs included
enough chit chatting let's watch watching
[Music]
is this a volcano they were
looking at a planet [Music]
oh that's Doom and Gloom whoa
there he is whoa
that's cool it's like an actual alien
coming to Earth this is the surfing silver
ah neat whoa cool that's awesome
all their diversity out in the first few minutes
that's where we live
oh we don't get anything fun
we just get a power outage okay
created weddings a fantastic couple Reed Richards
and Susan storm will take place this Saturday oh
neat unbelievable it's happening again isn't it
yeah sure we're not postponing anything not this
time this is going to be the wedding you've always
dreamed of and I'm not going to let anything get
in the way of that this is what's really at stake
just a little hobby of mine yeah I'm gonna make
a good toy or is it something uh sciency I bet
it flies I better flies do you think it surfs
in silver so listen I have a very important
wedding issue I need to talk to you about
bachelor party your bachelor party yeah yeah man
get it frankly I think Sue might have a problem
somebody told her that you were actually
investigating Global disturbances and Cosmic
radiation instead of actually focusing on
the wedding isn't this important though
like apart I've got a wedding to go to a
bachelor party could be fun but no exotic dancers
that's the whole point of the
bachelor party though right
that's what I tried telling my wife
uh wedding was delayed [Music] Doom
cookie exotic dancers what are they
you're Mr Fantastic that is so awesome
I didn't realize this was going to turn into
a fast and furious film I think it's worse if
they're not strippers and they're coming on him
they're just really really hot single women yeah
good evening and welcome can I help you no you
can't use that element oh I love him oh my God
and then it exploded and in a trillionth
of a second it expanded exponentially is
what became the universe we know today
you really put your powers to waste
I don't think they're just hot
single girls we think they're escorts
he is really dancing foreign
it's got that smolder going
uh oh oh you came at the worst time he had
never hugged those girls until just now
I was just explaining to the girls
don't say bang
you can buy one of our spy
satellites three days ago
if we're gonna find out what this is all about
we need a way to locate and intercept that object
might it be possible to build a sensor tie it
into the Baxter building satellite grid and we
can pinpoint the exact location of the object
you see I'm getting married this Saturday your
country needs your help the world needs your
help the wedding is that important I know
serious threat happening about what
you saw back at the bar worry about it
I know you I'm glad you had fun didn't
seem like that after she walked in it
was nothing compared to what I did
on my bachelorette party foreign
Wild she could get away with
more because she's invisible
she probably didn't even have
one Greg no it's a little game
oh you're making that thing for
the general okay don't tell Johnny
don't tell Johnny what that's why I know don't
worry then sticking together lying to your
woman lie to that woman you're gonna marry
man for Science and our country oh [Music]
Stanley named Stanley oh it's going by
Stanley nice try buddy not really I'm Stan Lee
so Marvel Comics exists in this world is my life
always going to be a circus do you love Reed
more than I've ever loved anyone
and you have nothing to worry about
the scientist is always concerned with her woman
problems General I'm putting the sensor online
now this is good you can attract the Silver
Surfer to your wedding cool I like drama
seems like he was avoiding the fear
who is just burying it deep down
[Music]
oh my God Doom's become a hyper scientist you know
you don't look completely ridiculous in that dress
is that obnoxious brother
talk for you look kind of nice
you look beautiful that's your sister you creep
lay off it man you're related dad would be proud
oh that's sweet let's get an
actual tender moment between them
you shut your cell phone off actually [Music]
the cosmic radiation can wait I've got a
wedding and as established throughout this
entire movie The Wedding is the most important we
are gathered here today to join this couple Reed
Richards together okay in the bond holy mantra
Reed seriously pull your [__] together we
brought that thing I know but there's a good
reason we have to get through this quickly
oh my God how many kinds of Love
let me just get to the end please
oh my God Reed what bro can't
you control it from your phone
all those people the wedding
are gonna die now via helicopter
[Music]
whoa that looks awesome that's terrifying
that's so scary oh my goodness cool
ah oh my God
[Music] ice versus fire [Music] oh neat oh
that's cool yes oh awesome oh that is cool
[Music] oh it looks great what [Music]
it's a cool sequence
can we talk what you doing man talk you win
whoa [Music]
oh no oh man
another world awaits let it be done quickly
it looked like a man but completely covered
in silver and it was flying this like like a
surfboard type thing I know that sounds
crazy so did you follow the shiny man
to Lollipop Land or the Rainbow Junction
to radiate cosmic energy when it exerts
itself randomly affecting matter evidently this
entity this Silver Surfer destroyed the sensor
we're dealing with something highly resourceful so
it's your fault the wedding was ruined
I'm not I'm not mad that you built this
it's like a correlation sorry and assuming
she's gonna be like don't do this thing
see this proves exactly what I've been saying
all along could you drop the force fields please
oh okay never mind I'd say get back we will never
have normal lives as long as we do what we do
how could we possibly raise a
family like this they would be
so lucky yeah they'd have like a little
superhero babies like The Incredibles
Johnny getting humbled this movie
does he have like a silver sickness
[Music]
Johnny are you okay maybe we
should get you checked out
I didn't do anything what is going
on what they're transferring powers
just hang on I'll get you okay [Music]
no what's going on
how did this happen
well where is Johnny here
oh no oh heck yeah oh
me because you're the hot one oh yeah it's
a hot one this should be every moment of
the movie ideally I'd like to run some more
tests do you like to fall into yeah no no
no no no no no no no hey I just wanted
to give him a hug it could be fun hey
hey it's me I'm back you've always
had the cape they have the machine
what am I supposed to do in the meantime just uh
try to keep your distance from us promise [Music]
trying to figure out who he's serving I
feel like it was the meteor or the thing
because he looked at that orange ball in
the sky and then he was like I serve you
just ignore it there's no getting
away from it I believe there is
what if after this crisis is over we leave
it all behind we quit I'll take a teaching
position somewhere the two of us will live our
lives and raise a family like normal people
it's not all that's cut out
to be you're a superhero
all right you're supposed to save people in
the comics they have kids really and it goes
splendidly oh well I didn't realize this turned
into Pleasantville you've been busy my friend
your talents are impressive can
you understand what I'm saying
I'm silver I'm not dumb all that
you know is at an end wait I said
oh you're in for it now buddy
whoa oh I thought it killed him yeah I
thought so too he like disintegrated into
Ash and what a nice normal boring
ass life what do they expect us to
do keep it going just the two of us and call
ourselves what the dynamic duo ah everywhere
the surfer goes eight days later and
Planet dies now we're gonna stop him
what about the craters interesting the craters is
what I meant I think he's serving the crater it
seems like a Galactus situation you know Galactus
yeah I I know all about galaxies I've never heard
of echolactus being in this so I don't think so
when I see silver I'm hitting them wait you can't
do that we've got to stick to the plan and work
as a team oh so we're a team now that's news to
me what are you talking about you know what I'm
talking about yeah you know this really isn't a
good time kids got a point Reed you should
have told them all right all right that's
enough we'll talk about this later what the hell
is wrong with you people yeah every fight is like
wedding family let's fight about it why don't
they just focus on being superheroes for a minute
[Music]
damn sue your powers are impeccable
oh
this effects are pretty good man
yeah Johnny do exactly [Music]
what a dumb dumb
[Music]
oh my God you're a better
Human Torch yeah science man
I wouldn't just give a head not if someone
saved my life I'd be like thank you so much
thank you so much was this like Pleasant
head knot look we have an understanding
I like that this one has an actual
threat though threat yeah there's an
actual threat here we'll make adjustments next
time we'll be ready you can't handle this alone
that's why I'm bringing in some help General
you bringing more soldiers and weaponry you're
going to put innocent people in danger
no more than you already have no [__]
oh my God it's face what's
the matter afraid of ghosts
it's clobber in time we need to work together
to survive you trust Victor and you're gonna
regret it so far the only one I've regretted
trusting here is you he's done so much for you
built a sensor they save those
people from the dying eye
the energy was channeled through him but it
originated from his board if we can separate him
from the board we can cut off his power completely
Doom is smarter this time I gotta tell you man I'm
starting to feel like a complete screw-up hey hey
I mean you kind of are you want to spend your last
few minutes I'd like to spend my last couple of
minutes holding exactly that sounds pretty good I
mean not the holding Alicia thing that's you know
I can't even think of a guy that wouldn't want it
what I meant was that it's just nice to have
somebody coming around to it it's gonna be
all right you have no it won't be the whole
world's counting on me and I just you just
need to relax yeah right you do you need to
relax take a deep breath slower there you go
you can already feel your pulse slowing
down oh so it's Paul's town a tachyon pulse
you did you did relax slow down learn
some information have a thought when we
activate the field it'll separate him from
his board making him powerless it's like
a fish in a net I can only go so fast
since apparently I'm working by myself
now you son of a [__] what are you doing you're
you know sue you could go invisible and
just kind of stalk yeah that's true then
she's got to put back on all her clothes it's a
whole ordeal Greg did you know I could create a
force field inside someone's body and expand
it until they explode if it's your best shot
at least there's like real scenes in this
movie too wrestler for in 10 minutes with
or without you will you just waiting outside
the bathroom to try and catch me in a towel
I was joking why are you so down on me you don't
even know me actually I know you very well there's
showers in the middle of an office all I've
seen is a guy that almost got his team killed
I've been a little off my
game lately this is not a game
I do like the emphasis on
Johnny you're truly maturing
learning it's real life it's not a game Johnny
you blew it this is a military what you
freaking fart Jesus Christ what what so
let me make it clear for you and your pack of
freaks here I'm the quarterback you're on my team
got it pack of freaks but I guess you never
played football in high school did you winches
what is this guy's personality I'm one of the
greatest minds of the 21st century and the big
jock who played quarterback in high school but
he's standing right in front of me asking me for
my help and I say he's not gonna get a damn
thing unless he does exactly what I tell him
yes yeah yes lay down the law starchy boy
give him what he wants all right that was
easy I'm so hot for you right now me too
[Music]
I have a problem he's here
it's Surf and silver
don't touch her
oh oh wow oh yep why are you destroying our planet
I have no choice there's always a choice I am
not Roger out oh it's he's protecting her yeah
whoa it's pretty awesome that's very
cool I mean the way they realize the
silver server is pretty cool all
right it's up fishnet [Music]
[Music]
thank you oh Doom uh
it's interesting how he morphs
into like practical design
we have work to do I want to be there for
the questioning that's not gonna happen
please make sure our guests remain here you need
the scientists there are certain things I'm not
permitted to do because they're considered
human rights violations you're not human
I like the makeup yeah he looks awesome he
protected me from the missile why would he do
that we need to get inside there and talk to him
under the radar if only there is clothes off lady
get stealthy the popcorn or something just to pass
the time I'll call it in Mr Stone great thank you
you said you weren't the one trying to
destroy our world then who is the one
I serve who do you serve you have to tell
me the truth who do you serve man come on
it is known by many names why people
called it Galactus it is Galactus devour
worlds yep all the worlds and innocent
people you've helped destroy my service
spares my world and the one I love how interesting
why did you try to protect me You Remind Me of her
account looks like Val Kilmer yeah it is not iron
I who draws the Destroyer here it is the beacon
what's the beacon the source of my power you're
bored I think he thinks I'm talking to someone
take joy in the last few hours you have left for
he is nearly here okay so yes oh it is Galactus oh
that's cool I saw the shape I helped deliver the
alien to you as promised now it's time to keep
your end of the bargain you can do your tests
on the board and in my presence only absolutely
he's gonna get all sorts of doomy and it's
just gonna bring more do me drama thank you
you guys deserve it for how
you treat it read yep [Music]
how did you devise this [Music] look
at him shaking [Music] oh boy [Music]
whoa
breed
huh we need to get the surfer he's the
only one that understands its power
even if we break him out of this place
how are we gonna catch up the victor
leave that to me I'm a scientist
the jet is it the jet pull that cover
off baby and show us what you got
[Music] cool where is General Hager
dead come out of here we're all gonna be
listen to me I'm smarter than hot why is
nobody like it's fond Doom girl [Music]
Booyah this is by far the coolest
thing you have ever done [Music]
that is pretty cool I did
dope are you serious are we
lucky at the sinking carry I could fly
circles around you shut up I'm driving
[Music] does he need to say flame on he didn't
when he was saving the London Eye which is why
I said it so I don't really know Victor is out
there somewhere with unlimited power and we've
got a giant Intergalactic Force that's about to
destroy our planet in less than 24 hours I've got
a lock on Victor's energy nice expositional recap
[Music] what the hell was that fixer the board is
drawing the Destroyer here you have to give it
up you know I've never been the giving type read
hahaha it's like a Power Rangers villain now
[Music]
holy [__] junk we're gonna have to split up what
this ought to be fun stay close to me cool [Music]
really pissing me off Metalhead
nice yeah
[Music]
you guys are becoming International terrorists
destroying artifacts left and right catch [Music]
no what just happened uh oh
he's gonna catch you and give us okay he's not
Doom you're being a [__] yeah he's being stupid
right now like really stupid I think there's got
to have a pulse in there linking him to his
board we take it out he's too strong for me I
could will on him if I could get close enough that
he could see me coming from a mile away touch her
she's dying you'll become invisible or maybe just
one of us we don't know what it could do to you
let's not make this about me it's time to
become selfless he's a growing boy [Music]
quote a friend of mine it's clobber in
time oh my God he's combined Powers Yeah
smart he's like a snake he's like Jafar
[Music] there we go you
ain't going down fighting kid
thank you
fun good luck swimming and all
that metal buddy he'll find a way
they always do so Doom's just like an entity
this time around I mean uh Galactus [Music]
they didn't just do it did they what
can he just touch her and she'll heal like when
Von Doom first touched him he started to heal
up right uh he needs his board oh yeah right
the whole board thing all right there we go
oh let me take my sweet time
now save the girl gotta go
not before I save her because she
reminded me of the one there we go [Music]
treasure each moment with her and tell her she
was right yes we do have a choice that's
cool surfing silver that's great [Music]
I think the serious moments it's
so much better with this one huh
I thought you could use a hand oh my God
what's the Silver Surfer gonna do how
could it how could he how did he stop it
I will know sir yeah talk some sense into them
oh he sacrifices himself
these are some great visuals
see his face there it is [Music]
that looks awesome
[Music]
priced like
thank you
all right
surfing silver you thought he was the
bad guy but now he's the hero what I miss
she is ridiculously attractive she is
hey wait hey changing that's right hug him oh
so I guess this is it
we all go our separate ways if it wasn't for the
team the whole world would be gone by now we can't
run away from our responsibilities and the people
we need to protect yeah you jackasses why would
you dare questions what about having a normal
life a family who says you have to be normal
to have a family yeah Welcome to The Incredibles
but the four credibles [Music] they want this to
get released in China is going on here I guess so
or is this Japanese am I racist you know nothing
science is sinking into the Adriatic
oh boy can we can we just to the end
oh cute call back I Now Pronounce your
man and wife and you may kiss the bride
hey all right
we should get out of here yeah she came around
I do like this one more yes
but only because of the ending
she's gonna catch it and he's gonna be like uh oh
[Applause]
burn them that's great yeah
well now you know reflex [Music]
right four in the sky yeah
waste your time [Music] foreign
skip to the end was the
best call back in this movie
we shall see if there is a post
credit scene well well well oh
he lives
there it is his eyes open do you see that no
then the board flew to him so it's a sign
that he's alive so he's like big and huge and
stronger now because he's living with Galactus
inside of him and he's also surfing silver
so he's like a galactic Surf and surf in Galactus
I don't know that's I know he's a surfing Galactus
now let's talk about it well Tara you have
officially experienced a Fantastic Four I
have franchise um what did you think about
it everyone thought you hated the last one
I didn't ate it but I didn't hate this one it got
good in the middle and the end and the callbacks
are my favorite once they combine Powers I was
like yeah there was too much yelling at Reed I
was like there is no reason for this guy to be so
upset at Reed Reed has only ever done the right
thing and built you the thing and been around
with his his lackeys trying to help you out man
uh so that part I did not feel as Justified I
feel like I mean the Army people yeah yeah yeah
like yelling at him so much I forget what his
name was but the sergeant yelling at Reed just
like left and right I was like why this is that's
the part I didn't like because I didn't feel like
I was justified like it was a little odd it was
just out of nowhere once you do this fulfill this
fulfill this you made one mistake oh my God you're
punished rough and we're bringing in Von Doom now
yeah uh yeah but otherwise I had I had fun I did
like this one better this one felt like a real
movie to be yeah yeah they have more real moments
right yeah yeah this this one felt more confident
more assured in how they handled the direction
um I like the way it was shot better it looked
better the comedy did not get better for me no
but this movie took itself more serious overall
and that actually worked better for me yeah and I
I like that everyone's chemistry a lot more like
everything I thought it was actually other than it
didn't get funnier for me I did like the bouquet
moment a lot at the very end that was great that
was a good moment that was hilarious but the rest
of it I agree with you I didn't really laugh that
much like when uh he gets into the wall and he's
like oh that hurt and yeah so I'm back here I
was like this isn't it's not hitting home for
me yeah a lot of the comedy felt a little uh the
comedy felt more off to me in fact that's where
I felt the movie was a tad bit at odds with
itself like I liked the first time I like the
first time the switching of powers happens like
when Jessica Alba is a fire that that was funny
um when Reed's firstly rushing through the wedding
that was fine there's like so few moments that
I thought were actually funny that I can recall
what each one of those is yeah like the first time
Chris Evans become uh gets the thing uh Powers
was fun so yeah oh but I thought there was actual
Stakes this time around yeah it was focused
it did because it it had like a clear threat
in villain throughout um I thought the visuals
were actually great they were really good they
were really great visuals yeah I agree with that
the whole thing with Galactus and the cosmic and
it actually keep it in Galactus obscured and not
seeing because I'll show you what like I'll show
you what Galactus looks like oh fun photo let's
go on a Galactus Adventure by no means like a
Galactus experts I've heard about Galactus for so
long I feel like you're saying Galactus a lot yeah
you feel like we've been building a Galactus
for so long the MCU that I've become so yeah
oh that's what he's doing that's what it looks
like yeah so cool at first I was confused like
okay I guess it's just a energy entity thingy
and then you would see elements and hints at
its face just very obscure but I actually like
the way they realize him for this go around and
I think it would have been a little too much
if they just made it like I'm another being you
know yeah because it is but to keep it focused on
Silver Surfer and and the flipperoo that's where I
was going I thought the first Surfer was a good
person so they have to have the flipper there I
like Silver Surfer performance a lot the comments
heck yeah the body language and voice of launch
fishron I like this one the first half hour that
was a little rough it was a little slow and I was
like why is the wedding the villain here I'm tired
of it like oh we like oh my God yeah but then it
picked up yeah I think in the first half hour oh
I was like everyone's full of [__] this is not
better this is not the better one this is actually
feeling more tedious it was at the when the when
he started rushing through the wedding when I was
like huh oh it's getting good oh this is a better
movie yeah this is a better movie overall I just
I felt like it especially in the beginning there
was all this talk of the wedding and they always
pushed Jessica Alba's character into like well I
need to write invitations and I have to dress to
get to and there's just there's no time like they
pushed her into this like she just cares about
a wedding and like being a wife so much and then
he's like don't tell don't tell her that I'm I'm
doing the right thing that we all are here for
with our superpowers like as if she would be like
no no you're not gonna and it's so funny because
that was another part that I was upset about
because I'm like she's literally never said don't
make that thing she probably would have been like
yeah we can postpone a couple of days because it's
not like you're sleeping with some people with
your bachelor party you're making a thing to save
the world right that kind of annoyed me that they
were like don't do it's a hush I thought they had
zero chemistry the first time around Jessica and
Reed yeah I know I keep calling her Jessica what's
her storm Sue storm yeah yeah yeah I thought they
had zero chemistry this time this time I actually
believed him as a couple yes I believe Johnny
and uh Sue as brother and sister yeah I I liked
all that much more and even for what they did with
because yeah it is in the first one especially she
is just you're hot and I think they I think
she was she's taught publicly about it that
they told her she had to just pretty much be a
pretty like they didn't want her to come across
um smart capable yeah like oh interesting and I
think they they transitioned her like I really
like the wrap around at the end where she's
the one rushing through the wedding that she's
not like not like oh come on rage like she's
the one like we gotta hurry this up you know
like okay this is that that actually absolved
a lot of that for me to watch her and to have
the connection with Silver Surfer granted
she is just like you know the woman still
looked like you remind me all these planets
and there's only one person right this whole
time yeah my wife uh so yeah I I still overall
liked her I like what they do with Johnny a
lot more too because oh yeah he really grew
yeah because that [__] could have gotten
old but they they matured him here except
for the burning the the flowers at the end
he's not gonna fully change I mean yes he changed
a little bit in a good way the first one had it
with the thing more of a character here he's just
kind of to the side I don't really recall what he
did I know he did some stuff what do you mean
like did he do anything in this movie like he
punched something once in a while he held that
he held up that that Ferris wheel or something
yeah he said flame on twice the thing yeah the
flame on thing what do you mean it's the flame
on he said flame on twice that's what he did Ben
Grimm the rock thing said oh my God you said that
you were talking I thought you were talking about
storm I said the thing like twice oh you did yeah
my bad you're not listening obviously not of
acting is listening yeah I know and reacting
reacting is actually the biggest part people
apparently they say that they're like acting
is reacting and I'm like all right everybody calm
down yeah if it goes in one ear not the other I'm
trying to think about my line is come on boys come
on now the thing what did he do he he he was like
listen I'll stop this rock and that hurt and he
said clobber in time once that's it oh and he
brought his own big cups to the bar because
he's learned he's learned and um he kind of
um he he did the flame thing with his finger so it
kind of Justified like oh your power your flame on
boy Power is cool because he got to experience
it that's what he did you know I don't um
I like the I like the relationship that he forms
with Johnny too here yeah it's much better it's
like it's like right they they kind of become
there's an understanding now yeah the more of
a Brotherhood you know what's weird is a Tim's
Tim's story the director of this he did barber
shop he did the shaft movie he just did a movie
that came out over the weekend I think it's called
the blackening got great reviews another comedy
okay got amazing it's got amazing reviews and
and yet I feel like his weakest spot in this
movie is a comedy yeah and you're saying Tim's
story directed The blackening Yeah Tim stores
that like he's mainly he does comedies he does
like what are the other things he's done I just
listed them you listed one Harbor shop the latest
Shaft movie oh my God oh my God I really maybe
I'm not but I have I don't think there's a maybe
here it's like I'm 100 confident you're you're
just frankly like not listening at all anything
I'm saying I'm trying to help out I haven't seen I
don't think it's been a long time since I've seen
the barbershop the latest you did right along
and ride along too okay Think Like a Man Too
Kevin Hart what now it was very funny
I did laugh at that and Kevin Hart is
hilarious so okay he does comedy but like
that's mostly Kevin Hart driving the comedy
still has like direct the movie you're still
like disregarding Kevin Hartz also does some
comedies that are not funny you still need
a good directory under recognizing that he's
good the effort that director makes to assemble
a film he's good I mean the the visual effects in
this and everything else great they're just like
we were saying like the comedy didn't really hit
home for me I wish they would have done like
alternates and been like should we test these
jokes to see if the pacing and the delivery works
like let's have some alternates and if those were
the alternates and they put it in then I'm like
yeah I guess they didn't have like that one that
bear in the woods thing I'm like like do you just
not know what to do with with the thing so you're
you're you're throwing in like this random joke
that's not funny at all it looks very expensive
because I think that's a real bear yeah and
also him blowing his nose I was like what why
are they doing these little bits with him and
I'm like I'm not laughing at him being like
yeah I don't think they knew what to do um
with that but the action was cool this time
around yeah I liked the first fight with Silver
Surfer when Johnny's chasing him and everything
on the freeway all the absorption and energy
added material shifting things were awesome
too uh I was I was surprised by how much more
I I liked that I thought this would just be a a
better version there's more they felt like a real
team Reed actually feels like a leader yes finally
I I felt that moment where he stood up yeah
unreasonable Channel quarterback he's like
you've now I'm the quarterback yeah I'm I'm
the quarterback now uh that moment was good the
the over overall yeah I don't really have too many
qual I mean the first one was just kind of like so
like all right that's done um fine and I'm using
entertainment like the first one's probably more
more naturally like it had funnier moments but
yeah what I didn't like was Doom I did not I
like the way Doom looks I could not I understand
they're going for he's power hungry and whatever
like I totally get that the choice though
for me was like this is so illogical what
he's doing though I agree because he's gonna
die in the process right this is so stupid
what he's doing he brings in Galactus like he's
gonna die too yeah there's no way he can defeat
this guy this the Galactus he doesn't know what
he's dealing with and clearly like listen and I
understand the choice like he's so power hungry
such a narcissist he's so eager so he's not gonna
listen like yeah sure okay whatever it still rings
as stupid to me it was it was dumb to me yeah and
it felt like it was just prolonging the run time
here and they just wanted to hit their 90 minute
mark on their film yeah because it's funny because
in the first movie Von Doom was like a smart guy
that ran this big business even though it didn't
really fully succeed but he did make that thing
he went out into space and like whatever yeah
he was a guy that like built this strong Empire
right and then it just sort of skipped to like
him being healed up but like a Darth Vader like
and then healing up to take another power and
I'm like bro like don't you have stuff to do
yeah like and I didn't get the general um yeah
is there something I completely missed about
him getting on board with it Doom just [__]
teaming up with him because I understand he had
information off the off the of the surveillance
thing on his helicopter that he gathered
but after that it's like do you try to read like
[__] Von Doom is clearly a bad guy in the first
like remember the horrendous crimes he did and
the first one to the point you had to lock him
in a freaking crater and yeah ship him off he
was clearly a bad guy so I think his service was
done by that point and they didn't even treat him
remotely close to being a prisoner they he was he
was like you're a buddy you know at the whole time
he just like got to do whatever he wanted which
is why it made me so mad that they kept yelling
at Reed and I'm like Reed has been the only one
basically working for you and then they they've
blatantly say out loud when the sergeant is there
of like looks like I'm doing it alone now and then
Jessica Alba storm goes to look for uh Doom yeah
because she's like I've got a brain right now
in this movie and why isn't he here helping him
um which she had much more of a brain in
this film I feel like for sure which I liked
um but I found that awe that I'm like why
wouldn't like why is no one calling him out
beside storm like being like why aren't you
here helping I brought the sergeant brought
Doom there to help them and then reads like I
guess I'm doing it alone now and nobody else
questions it yeah yeah that was that was was a
little odd to me that was definitely odd because
he's down there making his arm stuff so he can
do the juice you know yeah that was good stuff
overall though I thought the dramatic scenes had a
lot better I took it I was able to take it serious
the only part that would pull me out is someone
is the comedy but then when it's when it's sincere
heart shined through yes when it had those little
bits of humor I like I like those moments like the
end when they're all hugging each other I'm like
I really feel this it doesn't feel forced like I
feel this moment right yeah even Silver Surfer
being like she's right there everyone has a
choice like you tell her that I'm like I feel this
moment I like that I actually am feeling stuff for
this movie versus the last one which is kind of
a blank experience of amusement to me yeah yeah
um that I was I I thought this had more of the
emotional high notes and it's I feel like even
a third film would have improved it uh that
much more so it's nice to see that there's an
improvement on this and I can under I I wonder
if this one was a box office failure let's look
it up let's look it up before wrapping up this
video and like when he said dad would be proud
I like that a lot between him and his sis I
believe that and I was like that's so sweet
I felt like Tim's story heard the criticism
and knew how to to switch it see the the first
half hour though felt like it was having some
growing pains in the shifting and then this one
I still did really well I don't know why they
didn't get a third one what happened here the
first one it only made 30 okay it cost 30 million
dollars more but made 30 million dollars less
um which is I mean a lot of times
sequels will not make as much money
but that's pretty close it's not like it fell
complete like for a movie that was so panned by
audiences and critics to still come back with that
I don't know maybe it just still wasn't strong
um or maybe this one just kind of because I
know that I know both of these movies have
more of a Nostalgia now oh my God they list
Galactus right there in the plot description
they do Universal certificates so good I
guess and then I was like I could have just
read the plot description this whole time all
righty uh what would you give it out of ten
um the seven I would say a seven
as well last one was like a
like harsh and so like yeah five and a half
six yeah this one seven like a seven a seven
point five this hovers the ending is really
was my favorite part I was like the ending
and what is happening here I liked all
of it skip to the end burn the flowers
blah blah blah they all go off and I was like
yeah I like it there's solid stuff all around
glad we could do this franchise together
Tara yeah yeah now there's another one
another they re they decided to reboot it oh
and uh it's called fan it's Fantastic Four
yeah and they wanted to go for a serious
dark approach really telling you right now
it was not well received really it was
worse it is like really bad or what
I've seen it twice you've seen it twice I'm half
tempted just to watch it again with you yeah duh
what are you talking about there's another one
it's dark I gotta see it we have to do it now it's
not good am I going to be suffering like through
it how long is it 90 minutes of a bad movie I
can do it's on I just want you to ex it starts
off like this is all right two what's happening
2015. I want to say
an hour and 40 minutes 140. see people called
it oh okay fan four Stick because they put
the four for some reason as the a yeah it's got
Michael B Jordan oh I love him but I love um um
thank you so much I love miles I want
to watch it he's great just to see
your reaction why haven't I seen this
who is the who's storm Kate Mara okay
and who is that Michael Chiclet still
or no that is not Michael chicken okay
and they don't make they don't make him
practical effects oh they did he's all CG
I don't like it okay I'm half tempted to just
I think you should be fully tempted to just we're
gonna have to watch it it's just so I could see
her okay sit here I love all those actors I'm
like it's really it's that like not good but
well who directed it the 2015 one a guy named Josh
trank okay I don't know it's sofa there's a whole
story behind everything that went wrong with
that movie really this is just a disaster show
behind the scenes and it shows on screen seems
like just like a glamor magazine gossip column
waiting to be read yeah AKA by me the behind
the scenes is more interesting than the actual
can we like watch it and then we look
up the behind the scenes juice after
right that's the real movie well guys yeah where
do you rank Rise of the Silver Surfer leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe leave
a like ring it a bell ring it a bell ring of the
Bell that was a new song I just made up right now
I would give it four and a half Stars let's end
this with the patron of the day okay let's do it
aniso liver if I was Galactus I'd want to devour
you I feel like eating you would also allow
me to consume your energy and soul which is so
kind and giving fortuitous sympathetic and I
feel like I could finally be a good person but
it starts by doing an evil deed first yeah an
ironic part which would be I'd have to first
murder you by swallowing you the value would
be good that I would be good so you'd be doing
even a good deal what you'd be a better person by
sacrificing yourself yeah like to surf in silver
like the surf and silver you would be a better
person by just allowing yourself to die to make
me a better person and then and make my time here
more enjoyable and then Tara whatever is a really
really you gotta go Anisa yeah you gotta go
you've got a skedat and by skadat mean get eaten
get eaten hi Gregory out you won't even be buried
six feet under you would just be digested living
in there yeah yeah okay well that's a good talk
I hope you I hope you uh you know get your will
going right the stuff down that you want to give
away and like when do you plan on eating here soon
or like are you gonna wait I'm gonna wait for
a live stream oh oh good good good so you have
to invite her over right to like you yeah because
like Galactus like devours I'm thinking going bit
by bit on you and Easter oh like [__] knife if
you Super Chat five dollars we do a toe amazing
zero hopefully you know um so I feel like it
could be a real good morbid experience and you
got to be awake for it okay yeah that's that's a
tough one that's a real sacrifice but again would
take would make my time here more enjoyable and
and would take him into into goodness into the
goodness land well let's let's face it that live
streams I couldn't be monetized on playback so we
need to get as much super chats yes I mean
you better be chatting it and it better be
super yeah getting it done otherwise I'm stuck
here with him as he is and we all know that is
not anything I would normally sign up for but you
know I sacrificed my time to be here for you guys
you know because I know it makes
it easier on you guys when I'm
here because him on his own is just
like well it's Greg again you know
I don't ever say one main thing about it
thanks Anisa [Music]